tu t'es enfui de familles d'accueil aux
quatre coins de l'état je m'assume très
bien tout seul
tu tu assumeras 18 ans ces familles te
donne une chance tu peux bien leur en
donner une non je te présente billy
batson fait tout pour qu'ils se sentent
comme chez lui ils ont leurs gentils
mais faut pas s'y fier c'est carrément
jean de game of thrones y aller je
déconne tu veux me dire pourquoi tu voir
en noir tu es un gros handicap et à
adopter et à tous pour toi si tu pouvais
avoir un super pouvoir tu prendrais
lequel tout le monde dit pouvoir voler
tu sais pourquoi
pour s'envoler loin de cette
conversation non parce qu'un héros ça
vole attentes a besoin de ta fausse
famille pour te défendre
les gars je suis vraiment désolé qu'en
pensez vous
billy batson je te choisis comme
champions
[Musique]
il ya quelqu'un
prononce mon nom pour que mes pouvoirs
se répandent en toi monsieur se connaît
pas votre nom shazam quoi sérieux ok
shazam
[Musique]
c'est moi ces pays qu'est ce qui se
passe je connais que toi comme un super
expert en justice yamaska cap
est ce que je peux oui oui c'est un truc
de fou
c'est quoi tes gilbert pouvoir mais
super pouvoirs je sais même pas comment
pc avec ce truc tu veux aussi volé bas
pourquoi tu d'hyères
ce sera dur de ravoir les rayures votre
portable et chargez votre portable est
chargé du cwatupe voir et qui permet
shoah vrai
certes m
messieurs tu résistes aux projectiles je
suis super pares bol vous êtes mort
désolé pour votre vitrine et me
remerciez pas de vous avoir sauvé les
voleurs maintien ça va vous moi je suis
un super un euro